[Music]
it was a different kind of lockdown for
a group of 61 brits
they weren't stuck at home but in this
remote pub in yorkshire in northern
england
they came to watch an oasis cover band
and ended up snowed in for several days
people were willing to share and
just look in and get where they could
and then
the ones that um were supposed to be
sleeping in the tent believe it or not
they got to sleep on the floor
the weather forecast was poor but nobody
expected so much snow the pups doors
were blocked and roads unsafe to travel
but instead of giving in to frustration
the stranded guests decided to make the
most out of their captivity and keep the
party going
yeah it was good and we've had karaoke
we've had pub quizzes we've had board
games card games
and people helping to clear tables wash
up everybody's got on board with it all
standing at roughly 530 meters above sea
level the tan hill inn is known as
britain's highest pub and it's not the
first time that guests here get snowed
in
people came as strange as this before
it's a bit like cliche and there's a lot
of friends leaving
three days later finally came the rescue
but after sharing an unplanned long
weekend the guests are already talking
about a reunion here next year
[Music]
you